the rust of the heat and the intensity
of the celtics looks great
[Applause]
they're getting terrific shots and down
here
a lot of difficult ones and and williams
is having an impact
whether it's pick and roll or driving it
to the prichard richard's coming off a
terrific game seven
grant williams spins gets inside flips
it up won't go rebound tucker
hiro throws it ahead to butler oh and a
beautiful pass
just over the outstretched fingertips of
jalen brown
too many transition points for boston
butler jumpers
[Applause]
lethal from mid-range and i think it
started with pj tucker
coming back to playing in this half
vincent off the side of the rim back up
and in from minutes gone by here in the
third he'd have turned it around nicely
here in this period
butler saunders to the right side jump
shot is good
third and derrick white back in
as butler with another steal drives
inside stops turns layup got
[Applause]
and butler down the end throws it down
challenged by the heat look at jimmy
butler eyes ahead reading it
like a safety on a defensive back coming
up with the steal and defend lee wound
up losing in the final seconds
shot clock winding now butler has to put
it up he knocks it down
a two-pointer is a shot clock expire
[Applause]
richard trying to help out
now it's strews long three-pointer max
spruce
[Applause]
they're just trying to put pritchard in
pick and roll over and over and over
again
butler spins shoots over pritchard
drills the jump shot 35 points jimmy
the suffix have certainly missed marcus
smart on both ends as brown drives in
kicks it out tatum blocked by butler
rejected out of bounds
doing it all for the heat here in game
one
and until the fourth quarter he's got 13
in the fourth
butler pulls back one on one with tatum
backing in smith's pulling away it's
good jimmy butler with 30. grab it
screws the rebound out of lewis
butler gets inside and bangs it home
finishing touches
on another jimmy butler masterpiece